Salut la team mentalo ! Souvent dans les commentaires vous me demandez si j'ai des trucs pour la motivation ou les choses comme ça.
J'avais fait une vidéo sur la procrastination.
Je vous la mets ici, dans la fiche.
Mais sachez que le problème de motivation ça vient souvent d'un problème de stratégie.
C'est parce que tu n'as pas ta stratégie que tu n'as pas la bonne motivation pour avancer.
Aujourd'hui je vous présente un livre qui a été important pour moi, toute ma vie. C'est un livre de méta-méthaphore.
Qui a été écrit par un général chinois il y a 2500 ans.
C'est un texte légendaire, on lui attribut, on est pas sûr et certain, mais on lui attribut, c'est: "L'art de la guerre" de Sun Tzu.
A la base "L'art de la guerre", c'est un traité militaire. Je ne vous dis pas de faire la guerre, ou je ne vous dis pas de penser comme un militaire.
En tout cas pas pour être offensif pour agresser les autres.
Par contre, toute ma vie j'ai appliqué les conseils de "L'art de la guerre", contre moi même.
Ou avec moi même, dans un but stratégique.
Pour lancer le Mental Vlog, le défi d'une vidéo par jour, j'ai abordé le projet comme un combat.
Faire un défi, de toute manière c'est un combat.
Et j'ai appliqué à ce combat, toutes les stratégies que j'ai pu y apprendre.
Il existe pleins pleins pleins pleins pleins de versions en fait de ce texte.
2500 ans, c'est libre de droit.
Je vais vous mettre un lien dans le descriptif de toutes les versions que vous pouvez trouver. Il y a des versions qui sont commentées.
Très honnêtement, ce n'est pas mon kiff. Peut-être que ce sera bien pour vous, mais ce n'est pas mon kiff d'avoir les commentaires de quelqu'un.
J'ai préféré avoir ma propre opinion, ma propre résonance. Un peu comme dans livre, comme "Le code du ninja", ou ce genre de choses.
On y retire une interprétation personnelle qui est intéressante.
Et qui peut évoluer dans le temps.
Un de mes versions préférées, c'est celle-ci parce qu'elle est illustrée en terme de graphiques et de schémas.
Et ça on le sait, les graphiques et les schémas ça me parle !
Pour que vous puissiez bien comprendre tout l’intérêt de ça, et pourquoi cet ouvrage est si important pour moi, je lis un extrait, mais vraiment au hasard. Regardez.
Je fais comme ça:
Touc, touc, touc, touc...
Stop ! Stop !
D'accord...
[rires]
Ce n'est pas un grand extrait.
Je refais.
Et stop ! Stop.
Alors...
Qu'est-ce que l'on a... [lit la page]
"En prenant les dispositions tactiques, le summum est de les dissimuler. Si vous dissimulez vos dispositions, vous serez à l'abri des espions les plus subtils et des machinations des esprits les plus rusés.
Rares sont ceux qui arrivent à comprendre comment la victoire peut être accomplie à partir de la tactique même de l'ennemi."
Alors ça, dans un projet quel qu'il soit, je l'applique à chaque fois. C'est-à-dire que, j'essaie de faire mes projets en silence, comme on dit.
Il y a un article avant qui tournait sur Facebook avec ça.
C'était: "Faites vos projets en silence, la réussite se chargera du bruit."
Mais il y a un peu l'idée de cet adage dedans.
C'est-à-dire, si vous faites une préparation minutieuse, mais sans la dévoiler,  déjà vous allez créer la surprise, et ça c'est intéressant.
Et en faisant ce travail là, par contre, vous allez étudier toute la stratégie des autres personnes dans le même domaine pour vous en inspirer, pour mieux la comprendre.
Pour comprendre qu'est-ce qui marche, et qu'est-ce qui ne marche pas.
En clair, tout le gros boulot se fait en coulisse et doit être invisible.
Je vous lis aussi celui qui est à coté.
"Tous peut voir les tactiques par lesquelles je conquiert, mais ce que nul ne peut voir, c'est la stratégie dont émane la victoire.
Ne reproduisez pas les tactiques qui vous ont assuré une victoire, mais laissez vos méthodes s'adapter à l’infini variétés de circonstances."
En clair, il faut se réinventer en permanence. Il faut toujours trouver de nouvelles idées.
Quand je vous ai expliqué l'autre jour que je n'allais pas refaire exactement le même défi l'année prochaine parce que sinon ça n'a plus de sens, c'est ça. C'est exactement l'application de cette phrase.
C'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas parce que un truc a été cool et a fonctionné un certain temps, qu'il va toujours fonctionner.
Il faut chercher à se réinventer en permanence, parce que tout change autour de nous en permanence.
Je pourrai vous parler de ce bouquin durant des heures. Vous avez que c'est un truc, qui vraiment me passionne.
J'espère que je vous aurai donner envie de le lire d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Il existe dans toutes les médiathèques et toutes les bibliothèques.
Si vous n'avez pas envie de l'acheter c'est facile de se le procurer d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Tiens, vous savez quoi, je vais vous en offrir un.
Et ça, ce n'était pas prévu.
On va faire un concours... Je vais le faire par tirage au sort, comme ça tout le monde pourra participer. Si je le fais par mail, il n'y a pas à avoir de réseau social ou quoi.
Envoyez moi juste un mail avec votre nom, votre prénom et votre adresse pour que je puisse l'envoyer. A: concours@fabienolicard.fr
Et disons, lundi je fais un tirage au sort et je commande un livre sur Internet et je vous le fais envoyé à vous directement.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu.
Et que vous pourrez laisser un petit pouce en l'air, très important pour me le faire savoir.
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner avant de partir.
Puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an. Donc rendez-vous demain à 11H.
A 11H ! Je serai vous, je serai là vraiment à 11H demain !
Parce qu'il y a un truc qui va aller très vite demain... à 11H...
Donc rendez-vous demain à 11H.
Ciao !
[musique]